jeudi 4 heures du matin c'est valérie se
lève si tôt c'est parce qu'il doit se
rendre à l'hôpital notre dame
je voulais prendre le rendre un deuxième
rendez vous pour une résonance
magnétique de ma hanche
on m'a offert la possibilité pour que ça
aille plus vite dans le fond de
d'accepter au rendez-vous de nuit
dernier imagerie par résonance
magnétique permet d'obtenir des images
précises des organes ou autres parties
du corps les délais demandés par le
ministère de la santé pour avoir un
examen et de trois mois pour le
respecter
l'hôpital notre dame offre depuis
quelques jours des rendez-vous de nuit
des problèmes musculaires des problèmes
osseux on regarde un petit peu tous ces
types d'examens et l'a donc la demande
en demande de plus en plus la population
vieillissante
de plus on offre un corridor de services
à nos collègues de montérégie centre qui
avait des listes d'attentes importante à
l'hôpital charles lemoyne en montérégie
les rendez-vous 24 heures sur 24 sont
offerts depuis cinq ans les listes
d'attentes sont passés de deux à un an
depuis on a diminué nous les attentes de
plus de 50% mais malgré tout ça même si
on offre un service 24 heures sur 24
on a quand même presque un an d'attentes
d'autres établissements au québec ont
opté pour la même solution
l'hôpital du haut richelieu offre ce
service depuis septembre celui de sept
stages depuis juin à l'hôpital de
saint-jérôme le délai d'attenté passé de
42 à 10 mois en trois ans offrir des
rendez-vous de nuit ça semble être très
simples comme idée et puis une bonne
idée aussi pourquoi on fait pas ça
ailleurs dans d'autres départements dans
d'autres domaines et je peux pas
répondre pour mes collègues des autres
établissements je vous dirais que notre
côté on avait la capacité au niveau des
technologues et ça nous permet de faire
rien à peu près 10 examen de plus de
nuit effectivement pour que ce soit
possible
les listes d'attentes doivent être
suffisamment longue et le personnel et
matériel disponible pour cette
professeure en évaluation des services
de santé l'initiative est avantageuse ça
permet de maximiser la productivité du
matériel des ressources humaines et la
rentabilité finalement je pense que si
les gens sont capables d'aller à l'
aéroport pour à la cub à 2 heures du
matin je pense qu'ils sont capables
d'aller par un nième la nuit pour leur
santé c'est marie laurence de l'aîné
radio canada montréal